Watching TV should be easy
But way too often getting to your content
isn't easy at all
Android TVs solve this problem
by allowing users
to easily search with their voice,
see the recommendations,
and jump between content and games
just as easily as they do on their phones
And for developers, if you've already
built an Android app for the phone,
you're just a few enhances away
from working on your TV as well
Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
and this is an introduction to Android TV
I'm going to give you a very quick
overview of Android TV
and how easy it is to bring
your content to the living room.
Let's start with the creative vision
for Android TV,
which will help you understand
the difference between
building on something,
like a phone, and building for the TV
To sum this up quickly,
You want to create
an experience that is ..
Casual, Cinematic, and Simple
By Casual we mean that
it should be easy going
TV is not work
Picture yourself hanging out
with your friends in the living room,
watching a movie, playing a game,
or just listening to some music.
In a cinematic act, the interface
should fade away,
putting content front, and centre.
Tell your story with
pictures and sound
instead of text and menus.
and finally, everything
should be so simple
that it feels magical
minimize steps, avoid text entry
Just get the user to their content.
Android TV gives you the tools
to easily extend your existing
app or game, or create new ones
just for the big screen.
The most important thing
to remember here
is that, "Its Android"
It's the same platform that
you've already used
to build your phone apps
In fact, most of that code
can be used for the TV apps as well.
It can even be in the same APK
Here are the differences;
First, You've got to declare the activity
that's intended to run on the TV.
This is done on the manifest.
Second, You want to update your UI
to use the lean back support library
It's not strictly required,
but in most cases
It'll be silly not to use it,
because it makes it building a great
TV UI easy with widgets such as,
Browse Fragment, Details
Fragment, and Search Fragment.
The Leanback library
depends on Recycler View
and the V4 support library
RecyclerView gives you classes for
managing the display of long lists
in a memory efficient manner
Super important for TV interphases
and of course, the V4 support library
gives you all sorts of goodies.
The Third and final step
is to make your app
and content available to the user.
With the activity declared
at the manifest,
your app will already show up in the
apps or games section.
However, there's also the opportunity
for your content to appear
in the recommendations row
and through search.
The recommendations row
is the central feature
of the home screen
It gives users quick access
to dynamic and a relevant content
It's essentially a bunch of
cards that represent a system
or app action, notification,
activity, or piece of media.
You'll extend intense service
to provide suggestions
for the Recommendation
row, which will
help get your content noticed.
Search is important
too, because users often
have specific content in mind,
and browsing for that content
is usually not the fastest
or easiest way to find it.
However, you can
add a search action
in your app, which
you should do.
But why stop there?
You can also define
a content provider
to make your content available
to Android TVs' global search.
Android TV brings the
Android platform
to the living room.
Rich content, entertaining
apps, and gaming across devices
are now possible
in the living room
by extending the apps you
already have for the phone.
To get started bringing
your service to the TV,
check out the Documentation
and Code Lab as well
as these other DevBytes on the
Leanback Library and Search.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I look forward
to seeing your app
on TVs everywhere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]